I had a man take several steps into my
apartment he uh collapsed three steps in
and it's because he had misused a drug
that excites a man's sausage
oh my you know what that drug is but I
can't talk
but everyone is talking about Al Roker's
memeable moment you know it's a bit much
isn't it I'm a bit much yeah Jamila
Jamil's story proved a bit much for one
iconic weatherman that's one of the
things I've Loved about our show the
actress stops by The Today Show to
promote her podcast it's all about
dating it doesn't matter how hot or
smart or cool or funny or famous or Rich
you are you are never exempt from a
terrible date what was your worst day oh
God how do I tell this yeah if she tries
her best with a story that's clearly not
safe for Studio 1A I had a man take
several steps into my apartment or was
supposed to be my first ever booty call
he uh collapsed three steps in he broke
all of his front teeth they flew across
my apartment uh oh he split his chin
open oh my collapsed and it's because he
had misused a drug that excites a man's
sausage oh oh my is the only way I could
say that
you know what that truck is but I can't
talk
I don't mean to be outrageous I think
I'm just extremely blunt in a way that
we're not used to from women I don't uh
know how to behave Jamila replays the
moment on Tick Tock joking OMG this is
why I should not be allowed on live TV
you know what that drug is but I can't
talk so
our space will haunt me forever then
Jimmy let's press tour hijinks became a
Hot Topic on The View I wait three
months before I kiss or have sex with
someone so it's like the Hunger Games
trying to get to myself you'll probably
have to bleep this out I just don't want
to see you until I'm ready yeah
and that's fair
I'm so
I'm sorry
well let's move on a lot of people can
relate to that I was way more dignified
last time I'm looking at our executive
producer who looks like he's about to
die and before there was Roker face
snug someone who uh Tim to Meadows lucky
me
got to snog him and I've only kissed six
people in real life so I'm trying to up
my number kissing more people on on
camera doesn't count but um but yeah you
know I got snug so that's quite good
work on my score okay but jamila's got
one top score this week most TV Legends
made speechless and it's because he had
misused a drug that excites a man's
sausage
oh my is the only way I could say that
so you know what that drug is
[Music]